Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Du letzte Sendung ist ja jetzt nicht so lange her ist eigentlich öfters passiert.
Jesus ist auferstanden.
Na ja ok es hat er war letztes Jahr auch schon gemacht.
Ja vielleicht ist es nicht wirklich eine Nachricht.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 298 mich fast verplappert vom 24 April 2019 und das heißt.
Was heißt denn das eigentlich was heißt dass wir auf die 300 zu rasen und da hatten schon so ein bisschen Terminprobleme und uns schreiben wenig Angst gehabt ob wir überhaupt alle Sendungen zusammenbekommen.
Aber danach sieht's jetzt aus.
Ja das Sendung zusammenbekommen kriegen wir hin die 300 zusammenzubekommen ist gestaltet sich,
das hätte ich unerwartet etwas schwieriger als wir es erwartet haben es ist nämlich leider ein Gast abgesprungen sodass sie jetzt auch noch nicht mit unserem Sendungs Gästen angeben können.
Das schade.
Auch das dass du mein lieber Tim jetzt irgendwie in Spanien wohnst erleichtert die Vorbereitung nicht aber sie sind im vollen Gange insofern wir sind nicht wir sind nicht wir langweilen uns sicher kopiert Fall nicht.
Das stimmt genau und es sind natürlich auch noch Tickets zu haben für die Veranstaltung der dürft ihr euch gerne noch ein wenig bedienen.
Ja genau Veranstaltung am 4. Mai in Berlin im Babylon also in der gleichen location wie auch schon die lnp 256,
und wollen wir denn schon mal was vom vom Vorprogramm wenigstens erzählen.
Ja das können wir glaube ich mal sagen weil er können wir eure Mithilfe gebraucht.
Genau denn es wird als Vorprogramm geben eine Gameshow die euch allen sicherlich bekannt ist als das Familienduell.
Familienduell das lied das ich fand das immer ganz geil.
Hast du mal geguckt früher.
Also als ich noch Fernseh.
Pferde süchtig war.
Also nee ich habe ich habe nie besonders viel ferngesehen.
Aber das habe ich schon manchmal irgendwie nach der Schule oder so geguckt ja nicht vom 12 oder so kann auch sein dass ich bisschen früher aus der Schule zurückgekommen bin.
Die Grille rausgeworfen wurde.
Mit Werner schulze-erdel.
100 Leute haben wir gefragt nennen sie etwas das in einem.
Stefan meint ein Brötchen.
Meinten auch du immer das gleiche so so so eine schöne Rituale Vivi eigentlich hierbei Logbuch Netzpolitik mtv.
Einfache Regeln einfaches.
Das noch nicht eingeschränkt wurde.
Genau.
Das heißt wir werden euch ein wenig beteiligen jetzt im Vorfeld denn wir müssen ja auch noch 100 Leute befragen für jede Frage und dann werden wir schauen wie das die Ergebnisse sind welche Fragen wir dann letzten Endes
auswählen wenn uns also auf Twitter folgt watch space da wäre man das dann
eintüten bzw hier auch die Shownotes noch reinkippen wenn es denn Online ist das sollte jetzt nicht mehr so lange dauern.
Ja dann hoffen wir dass das dann ein lustiger Auftakt wird und ja dann in der Folge wollen wir euch natürlich wieder mit einer speziellen Sendung vom Logbuch,
auch ein wenig in Interaktion treten mit euch.
Wenn euch die Gelegenheit geben mal ein paar Fragen zu Fragen die euch vielleicht schon immer auf dem Herzen brannten.
Oder vielleicht euch jetzt erst gekommen sind wo ich die Gelegenheit gegeben wird und so im Wesentlichen wollen wir diese Veranstaltung.
Durchführen und wir haben auch oder werden dann auch für Pausen Sorgen ihr könnt auch früher kommen 17 Uhr dreißig Uhr ist Einlass.
Andere Hörerinnen und Hörer treffen und kennenlernen denn diese Leute haben was mit euch gemeinsam.
Die finden eine bestimmte Sendung gut und wer solche Sendung gut findet kann kein schlechter Mensch sein weil ich der perfekte dating Ort oder.
Der perfekte dating.
Power dating mit laufen.
Political Speeddating auf jeden Fall ich würde das nur mit Dir das mit dem Familienduell noch mal ganz kurz,
Douglasien weiß also wir sind einmal auf der Suche nach Fragen und die Fragen müssen eben welche sein bei Familienduell geht es nicht darum dass man die richtige Antwort gibt das wäre ja,
sondern dass man die häufigste Antwort gibt also die Fragen um die ist da geht wenn ihr uns welche Einheit sollten eben nicht irgendwie besonders knifflig sein sondern eben
immer so welche sein wo sie wo die Antwort nicht so.
Ganz gleich wie dieses Beispiel mit dem mit dem Picknickkorb wenn ihr da Empfehlungen an uns habt gerne in die Kommentare über über Twitter an at.me Unterstrich Netzpolitik oder so,
weil wir eben alle diese Fragen auch Leuten gezeigt haben müssen werden.
Gibt es eben eine Seite wo die Fragen dann euch gestellt werden wo er in eure Antworten mit eintüten könnt und die wird online sein unter Duell. Logbuch - Netzpolitik,
punkt.de also da vorbeizuschauen,
lohnt sich auch und dann bitten wir euch dann eben einfach die Fragen zu beantworten die euch dort gestellt werden damit wir dann am 4.Mai sagen können 100 höre haben wir gefragt.
Und dann geht's ihr wie weiter.
Ja und die Fragen sind im Wesentlichen in in einen von zwei colorite nämlich das eine sollen Fragen sein die sich im weiteren Sinne umnet politische Fragestellungen drin.
Und andere um Kraft politische Fragestellung.
Denn das wird ja unsere,
unsere Kernthemen hier also ich denke ihr wisst worum es geht es gibt eine einen Reichtum an wunderschönen witzigen Zusammenschnitt and von,
Familienduell Fragen und Sales und so ich werde das immer einen ganz ganz nette Sendungskonzept.
Ja soviel dazu kommen wir glaube ich zum zum Feedback oder.
Mama was soll man denn.
Ja ich habe in der letzten Sendung gesagt dass ich mir nicht vorstellen kann dass wir Gläubige Hörerinnen oder Hörer haben.
Weit gefehlt da kam mehrere Kommentare auf Twitter und in den Sendungs Kommentaren dann nehme ich nur mal ein Beispiel von Lordi um laudium schrieb und zu eurer Frage ob,
ja habt ihr aber immer weiter mit den Witzen vor allem wenn sie nicht einfach nur auf Klischees.
Und Vorurteile abziehen zu eurer allgemeinen Bildung in vielen Religionen ist es sogar durchaus Teil der Tradition z.b. im Christentum.
Osterlachen aus dem Mittelalter.
Wodurch Ausseer deftige Witze von der Kanzel aus erzählt wurden diese Tradition wird derzeit im Christentum wiederbelebt allgemein ist zu sagen werde ich über sich selber lachen kann der ist schon sehr nah am von am,
und das ist grundsätzlich immer schlecht also wenn ich ich habe gemerkt dass ich da offenbar einigen Leuten ein bisschen auch auf die Füße getreten bin,
ich bin persönlich davon ausgegangen dass der regelmäßige Konsum von logbuch-netzpolitik jeden noch so festen religiösen Glauben früher oder später erschüttert.
Umso schöner finde ich es dass ihr noch nicht aufgegeben habt genauso wenig wie wir und fühlt euch.
Herzlich geschätzt als Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer Verlockung network Religionsfreiheit erkennen wir.
Ja wir auch die nicht Religionsfreiheit also.
Verdi wurde auch in Frage gestellt also,
wir wurden mehrere Gespräche über das fliegende Spaghettimonster angeboten und also das ist ist nicht Thema dieser Sendung und insofern kann ich auch die Kritik verstehen wenn sich da einige ein bisschen
auf den Schlips getreten fühlen wie gesagt von mir aus sollte es eigentlich nur ein ein etwas misslungen David sein dass ihr hier eben,
quasi bei unseren Neuigkeiten ja dann doch früher oder später der glauben zumindest auf eine Probe gestellt wird.
Wir wissen ja alles gibt nur eine Göttin und die Göttin Iris dieser These werden sich sicherlich alle an.
Selbstverständlich könnte bis jetzt gar keinen Feedback zu bekommen weil das natürlich total konsensfähig ist.
Genau.
Konzentriere ich jetzt auch dass wir gerne 5g hätten.
Ja also vielleicht ne,
ich weiß nicht eigentlich wollen wir ja alle nur nett und ob das nun 4G oder 3G oder was auch immer draufsteht ist ja eigentlich irgendwie ziemlich egal und Sohn.
2G wird mir reichen.
Also wenn dann das auch immer erstmal alles da wäre ich meine es ja nicht so dass jetzt irgendwie alle so immer nur 4G voll langweilig und so gib mal 5,
nur drei Leute sind ja schon froh wenn sie drei haben.
Und dass das ist halt normal dieser Zustand ist wird einem Jahr immer wieder gewahr wenn man so wie ich sich jetzt mal so längere Zeit im Haushalt aufhält wie schlimm es ist,
also dieses Problem mit ich habe kein Netz.
Ist kein Gefühl was ich hier bisher gehabt habe in letzten drei Monaten in Barcelona einfach so ist ein Gefühl was nicht existiert.
Nicht dass man nicht irgendwo rum wenn Mama in der Garage steht oder so Keller oder so dann doch mal so,
bisschen die Verbindung verliert oder o2 Login auf einmal abgeschaltet weil er mit dem Roaming verkackt ist da alles passieren,
also generell gibt's einfach immer Netz egal oder oben auf dem Berg stehst oder irgendwo am Strand stehst.
Imbiss gut ich weiß schön danke toll toll.
Nur um das mal klar zu machen weil man gewöhnt sich ja also was auch ne und.
Man gewöhnt sich daran also so den deutschen erkennst du daran dass er das Telefon einfach so ein bisschen höher hält.
Neue deutsche groß Telefonnummer.
Ich habe hier kein Netz,
oh Gott naja aufjedenfall soll mal wieder alles besser werden obwohl es noch kein 4G gibt brauchen wir jetzt 5g und deswegen laufen ja gerade diese Auktion.
Und die laufen wohl besser als gedacht heißt es wird mehr Geld geboten als sogenannte Experten bisher glaubten man vielleicht erlösen könnte
das ganze bewegt sich immer noch so im Bereich von ungefähr 10% von dem was im Jahr 2004 4G alles rein geholt wurde damals waren das irgendwie frappierende 50 Milliarden aber Wind halt jetzt schon bei
5,4 Milliarden stand heute heute in der.
Wie gestern ist es glaube ich weiter gegangen ich habe jetzt nur den den Stand von vor Ostern und davon auszugehen dass noch ein paar Mark draufgelegt werden ja was heißt das jetzt das heißt dass wir wieder in dieser Situation sind
das
sehr viel Geld in die Hand genommen werden muss von der Telekommunikationsunternehmen um überhaupt erstmal die Erlaubnis zu haben zu investieren mit jeder Milliarde die jetzt hier Richtung start geht wird natürlich
Geld ausgegeben bei diesen Unternehmen die dann wieder reingeholt werden müssen in der Zukunft und damit gibt es halt keine günstigen Preise davon.
Genau du weißt ja die wird nämlich ganz klar wer diese 5,4 Milliarden am Ende zahlen wird.
Ja ja.
Der kleine Mann mit dem mit dem hochgehalten den Handy.
Genau
in dem Zusammenhang läuft natürlich auch die aktuelle Debatte weiter oder so aktuell ist die gar nicht also schon von Anfang an wurde ja das hat mir ja auch berichtet an diesem ganzen auktionsmodell schon ordentlich rum kritisiert
unter anderem das halt hier das ganze auktionsdesign dein geht schon falsch ist weil,
die Anforderung einfach zu niedrig sind man sich beim Ausbau bei dem erforderlichen Ausbau immer noch an Haushalten orientiert und nicht etwa an der Fläche weil sie aber wichtig ist dass man unbedingt zu Hause
Mobilfunk hat weil.
Mobilfunk kernig mobilist oder so weiß nicht so ganz genau wie er diese Löcher dann immer genau dann beklagen wir eben nicht zu Hause sind naja also bleibt abzuwarten was wie sich das hier,
weiterentwickeln wird.
Andere Kritiker meinen ja auch noch wann wäre jetzt auch ein Fehler dieser Einnahmen nicht dann wiederum wie es wohl geplant ist ist Breitbandnetze investieren das kann ich nicht so ganz nachvollziehen weil
was ist
Übertragung über die Luft alles schön und gut aber das funktioniert eben auch nur auf kurzen Distanzen und irgendwie muss man ja dann,
diese schnellen Geschwindigkeiten die man dann da erzählen kann auch schnell das Ei behindert bekommen,
also wird man an einem gut ausgebauten Glasfasernetz ohnehin nicht wegkommen dass es alles keinen kein unsichtbarer Widerspruch alles kussion wird weiterhin etwas schräg geführt.
Zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt können wir jetzt eh nicht mehr so viel machen die Auktion wird jetzt so durchlaufen wir werden dann sehen wir den Zuschlag bekommt glaube da werden wir relativ wenig Überraschungen dabei sein,
könnte vielleicht spannend werden was so Betriebslizenz and betrifft war großer Unternehmen.
Ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau wer es war das Siemens oder irgendeine und dann großes deutsches Unternehmen hat sich auch um oder VW was mehr so ganz genau auch eine eigene Lizenz,
bemüht und nur sagen für das eigene Unternehmen auf den eigenen Geländen direkt selber 5g anbieten zu können und dann über den Provider gehen zu müssen,
was ich ganz genau wie das ausgegangen ist wir werden sehen in dem Zusammenhang wird natürlich auch der Streit um waarbij weitergeführt.
Die Briten haben jetzt so ein bisschen halbherzig da einer Teil Entscheidung gefällt und sind der Meinung nach ja
VW ist ja wohl irgendwie böse und deswegen können wir die jetzt nicht in unserer 5g Netz lassen so ohne weiteres also haben sie jetzt so ein Beschluss gefasst mit
naja wir lassen Sie nicht in den Chor aber in dem Nonnenchor Bereich könnte man sie unter Auflagen ja zulassen.
Non-core Hansi non-core gesagt.
Ja ja Wasser.
Damit meinen die wahrscheinlich des rheindeltas radio access network also den.
Wenn es ist ne das ist eine Entscheidung die man wahrscheinlich auf diese Weise irgendwie treffen kann.
Aber es ist also noch mehr hatte auf die Gefahr mich zu wiederholen wir haben Whey Komponenten in den 2G 3G und 4G Netzen
ja sehr interessant sich jetzt aufgehängt bei 5g darüber Gedanken zu machen zweitens,
spannende Teil der dieser in der Zusammenarbeit ist auch viel eher die Integration ja dass du also diese wenn du jetzt erstmal wasted kein vertrauenswürdiges kein vertrauenswürdiger Zulieferer oder so.
Dann ist dein Problem dass du,
dass du denen dadurch dass sie ihren Kram betreibst der kommt ja nicht ohne Support oder so du arbeitest ja quasi mit deren Teams zusammen dabei dieses Ding in Betrieb zu nehmen und darum dabei bekommen die natürlich relativ,
große Einblicke darein wie dein deinen deine Netzwerktopologie ist wie die Sachen konfiguriert sind die kommen auch nicht umhin das ein oder andere Passwort zu kennen oder so nadijeh,
üblicherweise die Zusammenarbeit so gestaltet dass deine dass du eine im Prinzip vor Ort so,
Dienstleistungsunternehmen hast was dieser Hersteller unterhält was weiß ich in dem Fall würde das dann wahrscheinlich so was sie way services oder so heiße ich nehme das jetzt als generische Beispiele und,
mit denen arbeitest du dann zusammen in der Planung im testing und so weiter und natürlich.
Haben die sehr detaillierte Einblicke in deinen in deinem Netz Gefüge Internet Aufbau,
natürlich sind das aber auch Eisenhardt deutsche Unternehmen das sind in der Regel GmbHs,
ja weil du quasi als diese große Zulieferer Unternehmen unterhält daneben in den jeweiligen Ländern
in der Regel in der Stadt des Mobilfunknetzes dass sie David beliefern eine GmbH die im Prinzip einfach der deutsche Ansprechpartner ist damit die nach deutschem Recht unter deutschen Besteuerung und so weiter
vernünftig agieren können während diese GmbH daneben sich um den ganzen Kram was weiß ich Import Export China und so weiter kümmert na und,
das wäre im Prinzip da würde dein da würde dein Misstrauen anfallen und da bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher ob das so ein riesigen Unterschied macht wo die dir drin hast oder nicht ob die jetzt im Chor sind oder Imran oder was auch immer also ich bin der nach wie vor sehr sehr skeptisch.
Ja ich denke das sind halt auch alles im Wesentlichen Ausreden Großbritannien steht hier
einfach unter Druck von den USA bezw von auf den anderen leicht latent paranoid abgedrehten Teilnehmern dieser five heißt Konstellation als vor allem Australien so ein bisschen auch aus dem Leim gegangen in den letzten Jahren nimmt alles
doch keinen guten Weg mit der Politik da unten Neuseeland ist ja noch so halbwegs beisammen Kanada auch,
wird wenn dir auch noch mal
ihre Contenance verlieren weil sie nicht so richtig wie es mit dieser angelsächsischen Vereinigung noch weitergehen soll auf jeden Fall ist das alles ziemlich kritisch schon,
aber ist ja nun offensichtlich dass Trump hier eine America first Strategie fährt und vor allem natürlich hofft amerikanische Unternehmen zu befördern bei dieser ganzen Geschichte und
die ganze Argumentation ist halt auch und wie auch Absol pasiert 5 dieses Jahr war wie vor sie hätte ja Geld von chinesischen Regierung Stellung bekommen.
Ah ja super wie wie funktioniert der so technologische Forschung in USA eigentlich kommt da nicht um.
Internet aus dem Verteidigungsministerium also das ist alles eine absurde Debatte man sollte sich lieber fragen wie gestaltet man technologische Infrastruktur so sicher das ist im Wesentlichen eigentlich wurst ist
von welchem Hersteller du irgendwas nimm na und das muss halt ins Design und natürlich auch in die operations
einfließen oder muss man sich nicht über einzelne Player Gedanken machen weil was ist wenn morgen Nokia durchdreht oder Siemens auf einmal auf den Pranger steht oder Motorola ist zu nichts mehr zu gebrauchen ist oder wer auch immer sich sozusagen als nächster Anbieter.
Wann kommen die Schwedendemokraten an die Macht dann haben wir auf einmal die ganzen Eriksen Kram hier stehen also dass das.
Und jetzt hat man sozusagen den Nachteil wenn man wenn man sich nicht weiter im Netz diversifizieren kann dass man natürlich dann auch technologische Vorsprünge die war wer unter Umständen hat und davon ist auch sogar auszugehen bei dem ganzen dynamic die Elektronik in China seit.
14 nimmt das man halt dann irgendwann einfach von von Features abgeschnitten ist und damit eben auch von Möglichkeit.
Ich bleibe aber dabei der till also das denke ich muss als disclaimer immer dazu sagen natürlich mache ich mir große Sorgen.
Wenn Europa jetzt ein 5g Netz.
Und massiv im Prinzip mit Produkten aus China baut weil es dann wird sich schwierig wäre wer dann noch irgendwie,
den Technologievorsprung ausnutzen kann um überhaupt noch einen 6g zu bauen also natürlich für dich finde ich's aus Wirtschaft
förderungs Perspektiven total sinnvoll zu sagen wir möchten bitte dass wir dass wir die Kapazitäten die die Möglichkeiten die Ressourcen so etwas zu bauen
in Deutschland und Europa nutzen,
fördern und ausbauen ganz klarer Fall das aber eben eine wirtschaftspolitische Frage und keine Sicherheitspolitik.
Ja glaube sehr viel mehr, gar nicht zu sagen.
Kommen wir zu weiteren sicherheitspolitischen Fragen ist eigentlich nur eine Kurzmeldung als ist einfach so schön.
Der Maler Report wurde ja veröffentlicht ganze auch in der letzten Sendung beworben und der,
wurde jetzt es gab quasi schon das hat die hatte mich auch gewundert als ich das ist ja so ein bisschen nach suchte es wurden es gab quasi schon Angebote auf Amazon und so weiter und von verschiedenen eBook und Print Buchverlage,
den Maler Report dort eben auch käuflich erwerben könnte denn der Maler Report ist,
quasi von der Lizenz her gemeinfrei und das hindert ein Verlag also nicht daran dir z.b. einen eine gedruckte gebundene Verfassung davon irgendwie zu,
verkaufen als Druckexemplar.
Das haben auch einige Verlage getan und diese Verlage waren offenbar an automatisierte Urheberrechts Erzwingung Maßnahmen beispielsweise der Webseite Script.
Angeschlossen was dazu führte dass die seite Skript wo man einfach PDF hochladen kann.
Das und Präsentations YouTube ne YouTube für Powerpoint.
YouTube für YouTube für PDFs oder so ne also das irgendwie so ein bisschen um da eins runterzuladen ist ein anderes hochladen das war ich mal ganz schön weil der macht natürlich einfach irgendein PDF so
KURSNET in Textdatei auf gesetzlichen PDF da hochgeladen aber wie dem auch sein.
Da kam es halt die ganze Zeit zur Löschung des mother Report bei denen irgend uploadfilter durchgedreht ist und so verhindert hat,
das hier dieses dieses gemeinfreie PDF auf Script auf einer Plattform wie genau dafür da war ja genau dafür gedacht ist verbreitet zu werden und da kann man sich natürlich fragen.
Ja er fragte dann in einem schönen Tweet der Hendrik wieduwilt der bei der Frankfurter Allgemeinen Zeitung schreibt und Podcast it teilweise auch man ihn mal.
Dieses uploadfilter disarstar bitte einmal multiplizieren mit dem bei Behörden immer beliebter handrik sich zwecks.
Geheimschutz auf Urheberrechte an Dokumenten aus den eigenen Häusern zu berufen.
Also klassische tägliche Leben des Arne semsrott dass er dann irgendwie mit frag den Staat irgendwas er fragt dann sage ja da haben wir aber ein Urheberrecht dran ne das geht also ist genau in diese in diese,
Richtung geht's daneben das da dann übers Urheberrecht die politische.
Steuerung und Lenkung ein bisschen stattfinden könnte also.
Die Beispiele dass diese uploadfilter durchdrehen häufen sich einfach am laufenden Band wir hatten dieses Beispiel mit Notre Dame.
Und nine eleven aber hauptsache wir können automatisch rückwärts einparken weil das ist ja auch KI.
Ja das Urheberrecht es ist ohnehin ein wenig im Verdacht sehr viel weniger für Urheber gemacht zu sein als dafür.
Shady Geschäftsmodelle zu unterstützen bzw firmenkonstrukte auch zu erlauben man sieht das ja z.b. auch im
im Steuerrecht wenn du Zahlen Gewinne von großen Unternehmen aus den Ländern wo viel Umsatz gemacht wird abgeschoben werden in kleine Länder
die niedrige Steuern haben auch wenn sie an sich kein großen Markt darstellen also Niederlande Irland in Europa z.b. das sind ja auch
Urheberrecht zum Einsatz kommen weil dir einfach so
lizenznutzung Verkäufe durchgeführt werden um diese Gewinne abzuführen also das Motto ja wir haben zwar jetzt hier
Hunderte von Milliarden irgendwie Umsatz gemacht und müssen alles ehrlich sehr viel Steuern draufzahlen aber leider müssen wir ja die Marke dabei benutzen und es wird total teuer und deswegen fühlen wir dafür mal in irgend so eine komische Briefkastenfirma zum kleinen Land
riesige Beträge Abbrüche natürlich der Gewinn mindat und ach hoppala gucke mal da drüben muss man nicht so viel Steuer draufzahlen also.
Mache dir kein Pass auf aber ist alles ist nicht schön.
Wer ein Fass aufmacht ist der Verein mehr Demokratie und die beziehen sich auf einen Fall den wir glaube ich nur so
am Rande hier behandelt haben einfach aufgrund der unterschiedlichen Themen dichtet zu unterschiedlichen Zeiten.
Und zwar wurde in einem Jahre vielbeachteten Urteil der Organisation Attac vorher Bescheid Entscheid des Bundesfinanzhofs.
Prinzip suchen sehr nahegelegt dass sie ihre Gemeinnützigkeit verlieren wird also die Aberkennung,
der Gemeinnützigkeit die hier im Raume steht wo im Prinzip gesagt wurde okay Attacken mischt sich zu konkret,
in die Politik ein gab dann auch die die Forderung,
die Deutsche Umwelthilfe mische sich zu konkret in die Politik ein und da soll er dann die die Gemeinnützigkeit geprüft werden das ist etwas was wir in immer mehr.
Feststellen gerade und das ist eine interessante juristische Frage eine Anekdote die ich hier schon öfter erzählt habe.
War bei der Gründung des Vereines digitale Gesellschaft dir so in meiner damaligen unmittelbaren Nähe stattgefunden hat weil ich bei der Verein ja,
im Prinzip in den Räumen von netzpolitik.org und im Umfeld von netzpolitik.org gegründet wurde wo ich damals gearbeitet habe da ging es so ein bisschen um die,
Frage des Vereinszwecks also du kannst du machst du gründest jetzt in Wiedervereinigung Verein oder sowas Stiftung und dann sagst du halt hier was ist der Vereinszweck.
Und wenn die wenn der Vereinszweck dann gemeinnützig ist dann kannst du ihm auch beim Finanzamt diese Finanzamt für Körperschaften glaube ich diese Gemeinnützigkeit in der.
Diese Steuerfreiheit genießt bei den Spenden über die eingehen Steuerfreiheit für diejenigen die dir spenden Gemeinnützigkeit heißt impress
nur für anerkannte Gemeinnützigkeit heißt wenn deiner Organisation jemand etwas spendet dann kann diese Spende von der Steuer
abgesetzt werden wenn ich also an Fußball gucken im Chaos Computer Club gibt's.
Einige er Fassade Erfahrungsaustausch Kreise Vereine vor Ort die den Gemeinnützigkeitsstatus haben
das heißt wenn ich an diese erfasst Spende dann kann ich das kann ich eine Spendenbescheinigung in meine Steuererklärung aufnehmen und diese Spende als
Ausgabe quasi gewinnmindernde Ausgabe in meiner Steuererklärung vollständig gelten machen bestimmte andere haben das nie.
Und bei denen geht das dann eben nicht dann würde ich quasi diese Spende aus meinem versteuerten aus meinen versteuern privat Euros begleichen ja das heißt es,
es ist ein sehr wichtiger wenn du eine Organisation bist die auf
Spenden von außen abzielt dann ist es sehr gut und sehr sehr wichtig für dich dass du diese Gemeinnützigkeit hast weil es letztendlich dazu führt dass du.
Quasi Menschen die dir spenden wissen das kann ich von der Steuer absetzen oder eben nicht ist ein entscheidender Faktor,
damit nicht alle deine Trump Foundation aufmachen ja gibt es natürlich gewisse strenge Vorgaben dafür was gemeinnützige Zwecke sind und was nicht,
und.
Bei der Gründung von digitale Gesellschaft kriegt ihr dann irgendwann diesen schönen Brief wo drauf stand die Förderung von Grund und Freiheitsrechten,
ist kein gemeinnütziger Zweck.
Wenn sie denkt was gibt es eigentlich gemeinnütziger das als Grund und Freiheitsrechte zu stärken ne aber das ist eben der Hamster halt mit Juristen zu tun und nicht mit mit Idealisten.
Und genau so genau auf dieser Schiene,
geht es jetzt quasi gegen Atak da machen sich aber auch Organisationen die die Campact Sorgen,
weil Campact unter der Lesart dieses Bundesfinanzhofs Urteils eben als als Spenden Proxy ne eine.
Nicht klare.
Gemeinnützige Ausrichtung hat schwierig schwierig schwierig wichtig ist
wenn man sich jetzt anschaut Attac als ein wichtiger als wir wichtige politische Vereinigung Campact als ein wichtiger Kampagnen und und Einflussnahme politische Einflussnahme tue,
da muss man sich natürlich schauen.
Versichert durch anschauen was bedeutet das dann wenn man diesen Gedanken zu Ende denkt dann kannst du nämlich im Prinzip jede sich irgendwie politisch einmischende Organisationen,
also nicht mehr gemeinnützig sehen und das ist denke ich eben so gefährlich deswegen gibt's da jetzt vom Verein mehr Demokratie Rheine,
Petition in der sie sagen wir fordern die Abgeordneten des Bundestages auf erstens erkennen Sie den Wert zivilgesellschaftlichen Engagement für eine lebendige Demokratie und eine ausgewogene,
öffentliche Debatte an den dazu tragen ja solche Vereine bei stellen Sie sicher dass die selbstlose Beteiligung an der öffentlichen Meinungsbildung.
Sowie der politischen Willensbildung durch gemeinnützige Organisation,
unschädlich für deren Gemeinnützigkeit ist ja der auch das denke ich kann man hier klar.
Vertreten vor allem erweitern sie deswegen dafür als Sofortmaßnahme die Liste der explizit gemeinnützigen Tätigkeiten um.
Die Förderung der Wahrnehmung und Verwirklichung von Grundrechten Frieden sozialer Gerechtigkeit,
informationelle Selbstbestimmung Menschenrecht soll und der Gleichstellung der Geschlechter alles denke ich relativ klar vermittelbare.
Gemeinnützige Ziele die ja eben.
Uneigennützig und deswegen gemeinnützig sind.
Verpasste Chance dass sie hier nicht gleich noch Open-Source mit reingeschrieben haben.
Da kann man immer noch Gerda kann man immer noch ganz viel mit reinschreiben aber du siehst wohl worum es hier geht und wohin es hier geht.
Ich denke den dieser Forderung kann man sich anschließen denn.
Bin gerade mit diesen Forderungen mit diesem Engagement ist man noch weit davon entfernt das ist dass es sich hier Missbrauchsmöglichkeiten dass es hier Missbrauchsmöglichkeiten gibt und die.
Gerade so etwas stärkt eben die Demokratie und das zivilgesellschaftliche Engagement und das ist ja die Idee der gemeinnützigen Organisation man will ja nicht irgendwie dass da ein politischer.
Zwang,
drüber steht sich nicht politisch einzumischen ja das ist glaube ich gerade in heutigen Zeiten nicht besonders sinnvoll,
das zu da als zu streng zu agieren und natürlich ist das,
wichtig dass solche Organisation auch geprüft werden es gibt immer mal wieder irgendwelche Stiftungen die dann auch,
Schwierigkeiten haben zu zeigen dass sie das Geld satzungs und zweckgemäß,
einbringen die werden dann geprüft und das ist auch völlig in Ordnung aber grundsätzlich so was wie.
Willensbildungs Plattform oder sonstiges zu einzuschränken finde ich dann doch sehr schwierig und das kann sehr schnell noch sehr viel größere Kreise ziehen deswegen müssen wir da auch jetzt gegen vorgehen.
Gut dann aber noch eine Meldung zu Festgenommenen Menschen.
Ja ich wir haben das in der letzten Sendung ich mache das jetzt so zum Dauerthema weil ich das eben sehr wichtig finde
Ola bini den ich in den letzten drei Sendungen erwähnt habe gibt die seite friola beanie.at da gibt's einen Solidarität schreiben Sie den solidarity letter,
man kann.
Eine E-Mail an den Präsidenten von Ecuador schicken man kann dem Twitter-Account friola Winnie folgen man kann einen Newsletter bestellen also das ist da eine echt haarige Angelegenheit in der sich dieser schwedische.
Staatsbürger dort befindet sie haben jetzt gesehen wie es wie in Ecuador wirklich gerade der der Wind des politischen Wandels weht und da.
Will man tatsächlich zu sehen dass wir da zu sehen und ein Auge drauf haben was mit olabi nie passiert gleichzeitig.
Haben wir öfter behandelt das Schicksal des Louis auch TTC Ehrenmitglied Chelsea Manning die jetzt eine Beschwerde,
vorgebracht hat in vor dem Gericht in Virginia gegen ihre Jahre Haft in der sie sich da befindet diese,
seit ich glaube ungefähr eineinviertel moi eineinhalb Monaten oder so in der wurde aber ihre Ihr Widerspruch ihrem Widerspruch wird nicht stattgegeben sie muss weiter.
In Haft bleiben seit dem 8. März ist hier in Haft also seit anderthalb Monaten.
Weil sie eben sagt sie hat keinen Anlass dieser Gregory gegenüberzutreten das sieht die Grandstream anders und das Gericht.
Versuch das irgend eben dazu.
Durch Beugehaft zu erzwingen es geht dabei um einen Verfahren.
Gegen Julian Assange wo wir ja jetzt auch natürlich die größeren Zusammenhänge kennen.
Wenn wir an das Auslieferungsgesuch denken was die usada anstreben und es ist eigentlich auch wir haben ja.
Unterschiedlich also meistens wenn man sich wenn man sich richtig bemüht ausgewogen über ein Thema zu sprechen dann kommen die Leute die sich beschweren und würde es immer wenn wir über Julien Assange reden.
Es ist natürlich nicht.
Zu nicht zu verheimlichen und in uns nicht entgangen dass die USA einerseits sagen hier wir beschuldigen den Türen erforsche hätte er hat er vor.
Angeboten ein Passwort zu knacken und deswegen wollen wir den jetzt sofort ausliefern wegen Verschwörung während wir an anderer Stelle uns anschauen wir haben.
10 deutliche Anhaltspunkte dass US-Präsident Donald Trump,
bemüht war mit den Russen zusammen zu arbeiten und sich mit denen zu auseinanderzusetzen wir haben außerdem Anhaltspunkte dass er,
obstruction of Justice zu begehen also die Behinderung der Justiz hört durch das Feuern von Maler durch irgendwelche durch das nahelegen von Falschaussagen und das immer nur contained wurde von seinen
Mitarbeiter die gesagt haben die dann mache ich einfach nicht,
die Akte nehme ich wieder von dem Tisch runter und hoffe dass er das vergessen hat wenn er den nächsten Tweet gesehen hat und so verhindert haben dass er aktiv dass er tatsächlich obstruction of Justice begehen konnte obwohl er es wollte.
Es hat sich schon interessanter. Als Julian Assange,
nur für das Angebot ein Passwort zu knacken hier jetzt ausgeliefert werden soll und der wird natürlich noch viel mehr kommen und gleichzeitig immer sagt na ja hier der Donald Trump der 210 Anläufe unternommen,
aber es ist ihm ja nie geglückt insofern sorry.
Das ist die zweierlei Maß mit denen da gemessen wird können wir wir sehen und gerade olabilir und Schätzchen Menningen sind wirklich die letzten die da und das Rad kommen soll und gegen die Auslieferung Julien US soldiers.
Haben wir unser auch immer wieder streng.
Auf gesprochen also da müssen gehören eure Augen hin da geht es jetzt darum.
Die Freiheit und die Pressefreiheit zu verteidigen.
Was hat sie denn schon Artikel gelesen von den Botschaftsmitarbeiter die so über Julien Assange berichtet haben zu was er da so getrieben haben soll.
Ja aber das dass das sehe ich auch so ein bisschen als als als als Nebelkerze und Ablenkungsmanöver dass diese diese Situation da so zu Boulevardisierung ne.
Ja na ja ich meine das habe jetzt kein Problem aber da irgendwie Skateboard fährt oder was er da irgendwie macht überhaupt meine Hose an hat beim Podcasten das haben wir ja auch nicht so lustig dass sie Neroli genannt haben da war er war sehr nicht ganz so weit weg von uns.
Das hatte ich sowieso sehr gut gehalten also das mit dem Rudi oder Sanchez dass der Server.
Wann ist die schlechteste Eingabe.
Daran nicht.
Ja lp300 haben wir jetzt schon angekündigt.
Genau helft uns bei der Vorbereitung des Familienduell sunter Duell. Logbuch - Netzpolitik. De ihr könnt euch über die sendung informieren unter Logbuch - Netzpolitik Schrägstrich
300 aufgeschrieben der Link für den Vorverkauf pritex EU Schrägstrich NMP Schrägstrich in MP300.
Wir freuen uns auf euren Besuch wir freuen uns wenn ihr außerdem noch einen,
T-Shirt mit dem Test gibt denen nacht ab Modell den Standardpreis den ermäßigten Preis und den politischen Preis ihr könnt im Prinzip bezahlen was ihr möchtet.
Und wir garantieren euch seit Wochen mit nichts anderem beschäftigt zu sein als euch da gute Unterhaltung.
Und gutes Brainfood zu präsentieren mit euch diesen Abend zu feiern.
Ja und wir wollen ja auch möglichst viele neue Hörerinnen und Hörer Kennenlernen von daher gibt euch einen Ruck da mal vorbeizuschauen wird auf jeden Fall die Gelegenheit geben für ein kurzes Gespräch mit jedem.
Der sich unsicher notes.
Das hat irgendein.
Traut sich ja nicht jeder.
Worauf der Tim hinaus möchte ist wir werden am Ende auch eine so ein bisschen.
Offene Fragen was ihr immer schon mal fragen wolltet.
Da könnt ihr euch dann David Prinzip da muss es dann gar nicht um die Sendung gehen dann muss es vielleicht auch gar nicht um Netzpolitik gehen.
Von mir wenn wenn interessant würden wir da sogar diese die klassischen Chor Referate erst nach kurzer Zeit niederschlagen nein also
ihr habt ihr habt die Gelegenheit da einfach mal auch wir wollen mit den Sendungen immer ein bisschen auf die,
auf die metaperspektive auf die Metaebene gehen und,
da interessiert uns auch euer Blick da drauf also,
bereitet euch schon mal darauf vor dass ihr wenn ihr da eine Frage habt ihr schon immer mal stellen wollte.
Keine Frage ist zu zu naiv oder zu böse oder zu falsch dann könnt ihr die mitbringen und seid darauf vorbereitet dass sie die am Imre Laufe dieses Abends gerne in ein Mikrofon soll sein könnt,
und unter Umständen sogar eine freundliche Antwort von uns bekommt ansonsten wir auch einen Saalschutz.
Bevor er fragt es wird wahrscheinlich kein Streaming geben weil wir vermutlich auch keine Videoaufzeichnung machen von daher alles hochexplosiv an diesem Abend,
trotzdem die Sendung wird natürlich in Audio aufgenommen und dann später ja auch ein Podcast veröffentlicht also geht jetzt nichts komplett verloren.
So siehts aus und außerdem würden wir gerne noch darauf hinweisen dass die Privacy Policy,
crazy week Stuttgart vom 17 bis 26.05 stattfindet in Stuttgart und durch die inzwischen achte North bei Konferenz am 17.05 eröffnet wird.
Am 25.06 20:15 Uhr noch eine IT security Konferenz die beside in Stuttgart also da geht's richtig rund eine ganze,
Privatsphäre Woche in Stuttgart Link dazu findet ihr bei uns in den Charts mit vielfältigen Events in Stuttgart.
Und damit sind wir glaube ich am Ende angekommen und können danken ich danke Margreth hanno Niklas und Michael.
Genau und wir danken allen Spendern und Unterstützern und Ideen die Fahnen kommentiere Rennen und KritikerInnen und was auch immer ja alles tut.
Mach weiter damit wir sehen uns in wenigen Tagen hören wir uns schon wieder und dann sehen wir uns hoffentlich in Berlin am viermal bis dann.